[Music]
it's time for the keynotech news not
only can you expect the first images of
the new Godzilla series but also the
latest information on the planned
Fallout adaptation also the director of
The Equalizer 3 has announced that this
is not necessarily the last movie in the
franchise all this and much more is
waiting for you in this week's keynotech
news
the DC film Blue Beetle by director
Angel Manuel Soto was released in
theaters just a few days ago now The
Wrecking Crew is his next project the
MGM produced film is expected to feature
a top-notch cast including Dave Batista
and Jason Momoa both of whom are in
talks before the current actor strikes
screenwriter Jonathan shropper has also
been hired he was previously in charge
of series such as Warrior and Banshee
and has also worked with Jason Momoa on
the Apple series C tropper was hired for
the project prior to the writer stripe
Mamoa talked about the project back in
2021 in an interview with James Corden
quote Dave loves wearing speedos I love
wearing board shorts and both of us with
our shirts off I have hair he doesn't
have hair we cover all the demographics
yet the two have clearly proven that
they are capable of more in recent years
Momoa for example was able to excel as a
villain in the last Fast and Furious 10.
and as Aquaman helped DC to one of its
biggest movie hits Dave Batista means
while played his way into the fans of
Hearts as Drax in the popular Guardians
of the Galaxy series or won them over in
his brief appearance in Dennis
villenev's Blade Runner 2049 speaking of
Dennis Villeneuve both actors have even
starred in a movie together namely in
the 2021 science fiction epic Dune where
they were on opposing signs this will
probably be a bit different in the Buddy
comedy Wrecking Crew currently nothing
is known about the planned release date
of the action movie
more equalizer movies with the
rejuvenated Denzel Washington if
director Antoine Fuqua has his way
that's absolutely possible The Equalizer
3 will soon be the last mission with
Denzel Washington in the leading role
for now the final part is supposed to be
the main character's ultimate exit from
the life of an Avenger director Antoine
Fuqua indicated in an interview with nmw
however that this does not necessarily
mean that we will no longer see Denzel
Washington in the role in fact Fuqua has
already thought about rejuvenating his
leading man to continue the franchise in
the form of a prequel if there were a
good way of telling Robert McCall's
original story then talks could be held
out the fact that the de-aging of actors
has become a popular means of
Storytelling is hardly a novelty this
year Ramon we saw a rejuvenated Harrison
Ford in Indiana Jones 5. however this
technique continues to be met with
criticism as it is still partly
perceived as artificial Fuqua emphasized
that he would keep an eye on the process
and therefore had not yet spoken to
Denzel Washington about it he also
reported on the shoe shooting of The
Equalizer 3 and revealed that it was
quite exhausting for Washington there
was a scene in which the star had to run
up a flight of stairs the scene could
only be repeated a few times because of
the physical strain on the 68 year old
actor quote from the director his knees
were hurting it was hot too of course we
wonder even if you could make an actor's
face look believably younger isn't it a
problem especially in action scenes when
a supposedly young character moves like
an older person even the Irishman by
star director Martin Scorsese faced some
ridicule when a rejuvenated Robert De
Niro beat up someone while physically
looking like he was in his mid-70s what
are your thoughts on the subject should
The Equalizer finally retire or do you
think we can still expect some great
movies with the Aging we are looking
forward to reading your opinion
at last there are new details about the
Fallout series a teaser trailer and an
approximate release date for the live
action adaptation of the popular game
series was revealed at Gamescom the
series is set to kick off soon on Amazon
Prime video Fallout is a real Evergreen
in video game history many games of the
post-apocalyptic role-playing series
have been released since 1997 and are
very popular to this day as early as
July of 2020 a series adaptation was
announced by Amazon via deadline and put
fans in great anticipation now the first
information and approximate release date
for the series adaptation have finally
been made public at the Gamescom event
that is currently taking place in
Germany Fallout will be available on
Amazon Prime video as soon as next year
in 2024 as already announced in 2020
Christopher Nolan's brother Jonathan and
his wife Lisa Joy will be in charge of
the series Jonathan Nolan already wrote
the scripts for Interstellar and
Westworld and will also work as a writer
for the Fallout series the two will also
produce the series as well as direct the
First episodes the cast includes Moises
Arias Johnny Pemberton aiksa Kendrick
and the hateful eight star Walton
Goggins moreover the studio presented
first glimpses in the form of a teaser
trailer which however was exclusively
shown to the visitors of the exhibition
up to now there is only one description
of the trailer there is footage of the
so-called Brotherhood of Steel this is
followed by a firefight in which the
Brotherhood is in ball you can also see
a woman leaving her Vault for the first
time and discovering the
post-apocalyptic World vault is the name
given to the numerous bunkers where
people sought shelter from World War III
Amazon Prime also published a first
artwork of the series on Twitter which
shows us the well-known Vault boy in the
setting of Los Angeles The Vault boy
wears the typical blue suit of the Vault
inhabitants a 33 can be seen on his
chest this suggests that the series will
focus on the survivors of Vault 33 and
that the action will take place in and
around La The Fallout video games tell
of a post-apocalyptic world destroyed by
a nuclear war in the year 2077 the
players explore the radioactively
contaminated Earth and have to deal with
the likes of mutants scavengers and
strange Cults besides a decent amount of
humor the style of the American 1950s is
a signature feature of the series we are
excited to see if the special atmosphere
of the games will carry over to the
series
monster fans listen up Apple has
presented us with the first images of
the title of their upcoming Godzilla
series Monarch Legacy of monsters is set
to build on legendary's monster verse
and follow up on the Godzilla movie from
2014. the series will therefore also be
set in the same universe as the previous
movies Kong Skull Island Godzilla king
of monsters and Godzilla vs Kong the
series will cover three generations and
follow two siblings in particular they
want to follow in their Father's
Footsteps and uncover their family's
connections to the secret organization
Monarch the respective storylines will
take place in 1950 and half a century
later and will once again take us into
the world of Godzilla and other famous
kaijus the title of the series Monarch
Legacy of monsters also suggests that
the series will mainly revolve around
the secret organization that has been
dealing with the Titans for ages Matt
shackman who has already made a name for
himself with series like succession the
boys and one division will direct the
first three episodes information and
first pictures of the cast have also
been revealed we see Kurt Russell in the
role of army officer Lee Shaw as well as
his son Wyatt Russell as a young version
of the character in the 1950s likewise
we get a look at a character embodied by
Anna sawai looking up at the sky in fear
possibly seeing the king of all monsters
up close at this very moment this seems
to be confirmed by another image in
which we see the Roaring Godzilla a
woman is standing in the front since the
series will cover three generations and
several decades it'll probably have an
adequate length with the announced 10
episodes of the first season an exact
release date is not known yet but the
series is expected to Premiere next year
this is a reason to Rejoice for all fans
of the iconic monster who can already
look forward to Godzilla x-con the new
Empire and tohos Godzilla minus one
an unusual follow-up after the extremely
successful Frozen movies not only a
third part is to come but also a podcast
with the title Disney's Frozen podcast
forces of nature which is meant to
connect part 2 and part three Disney's
Frozen was a phenomenal success grossing
over 1.2 billion dollars worldwide
Frozen 2 which was released in 2019 even
managed to top that with 1.4 billion
dollars so it should come as no surprise
that the company wants to further expand
the world around Snowman Olaf Elsa and
Anna thus short films and short stories
came out Frozen 3 was announced in
February of this year and now a 12-part
audio series is to follow with forces of
nature which will present us with
Further Adventures of the main
characters between the second and third
film in addition to the familiar
characters Elsa Anna Olaf and Kristoff
new characters will also make an
appearance in the audio series for
example Lord Wolfgang the nephew of the
Duke of Wessel and as pet magpies Astrid
and Magnus also new to the story is
Queen disa who like Anna rules over her
own kingdom currently it is not known
whether the original Stars will lend
their voices to the characters according
to a first trailer for the podcast
Kristen Bell and Indina Menzel seem to
be unavailable while Jonathan Groff and
Josh Gann will once again be heard as
Christoph and obof
and that concludes the news of the week
we hope you like this video If you
haven't had enough you should check out
our latest original where we present you
the best upcoming action movies of 2023
and 2024. The Equalizer 3 is of course
kicking things off with its release next
week thanks for watching and we'll see
you next time
[Music]
thank you